we've come to the vast and remote
outback of western australia in the
pilbara region
[Music]
here you can find one of the most sought
after substances in the world right now
it's an essential ingredient in making
batteries called spoogamine which once
refined becomes lithium a key component
in decarbonizing the world
why is it so important well with all net
growth in car sales last year coming
from electric vehicles demand for the
raw materials in batteries has ramped up
suddenly this particular site the
pilgangora all body is one of the
largest hard rock lithium deposits in
the world and is considered
strategically important within the
global lithium supply chain
there's a number of ways to get lithium
out of the earth
one is to pump underground water up to
the surface and then evaporate the
mineral-rich brine out in the sun
leaving behind dried salts that include
lithium crystals
here in the moonscape dry outback the
method's one of extracting the clay or
ore and separating the metal through a
complex process
pilbara's pier called liontown which is
just 600 miles up the road
recently struck a deal with american car
maker ford uh worth 300 million to help
expand their minds that comes after
another recent deal the company made
with tesla on top of that another
automaker in europe stalantis which is
the owner of the fiat and chrysler
brands took a stake in australian
lithium producer vulcan energy of course
with all this demand more lithium
production is sure to come online but it
won't be easy it takes anywhere from 18
months to build a processing facility to
seven years to build an entire mine
[Music]